welcome to this video playing undone
from Germany um yo maybe maybe go for
kings in you know I see one of those
boring guys yep he is not as boring as a
Bishop f4 but still aha so maybe he
wants to play if already maybe oh
there's some way to get get this
non-symmetrical something a bit more
enterprising benoni style Queen B 6 can
I do that trying to retighten ose go
into nope is not sacrificing upon ok so
we're going to play benoni with white
having played the somewhat strange move
rupee one I might even okay well Bishop
f5 you might play 92 m maybe I can host
again this tempo here or let's say ask
the bishop where it wants to go really
to f1 wow
maybe I can play 90 for him or be five
maybe look at this but he can go nighty
too right that's that's possible 92 m
maybe he needs to do that 94 is quite an
annoying threat no he goes one in
typical style the most passive move so
young still not easy to do anything with
black yeah we can play a discovered move
with the noid but not leading to too
much
I only should avoid be 5 p-5 night x x 5
but here maybe i can get Queen c7 n with
c4 and this kind of idea but it can go a
for now I am preventing b5 you will
probably do that maybe a 4c for Bishop
b2 95 maybe not bad ok I'm going to to
do this if you get the chance to expand
like that and the Benoni you should
normally do it and it does not really
feel like it's very comfortable with our
the whole position
great preparing night be one okay yeah
so then do your worst go to be one so
even even see for now pushing pushing it
back yeah let's do it 95mm is what I
want to do next but I want to have
before protected so and he's attacking
those pawns 95 takes Knight takes e4 I
am and
maybe I should keep it protected for the
moment i also have bishop a six sorry
ship a six to protect this one drawback
is 94 94 to c6 that's something that you
can try
you should basic salad let's keep it
protected from the moment if he came in
case of a capture on before I mean I
want to have c4 covered 94 somewhat
worrying me it is not going forward at
all 95 now takes be form
I can take before it's really not that
clear but okay this this looks like the
the one that should be is doing
something else just just T just taking
okay and this I didn't consider it or
simply looks too passive but maybe maybe
it's not that bad mighty seven maybe can
play whoopsie one maybe try to again
threaten who or that one and which has
96 at least on the agenda not clear can
take Queen a three
now that's an annoying piece to appear
them i don't know if i should take
really
now the night appearing there is a
problem it really is and I cannot even I
cannot sacrifice the exchange just like
that it's not possible hi morning maybe
I can do this okay knight c6 takes 95
and tending 92 d3 now tricky
I don't know dude interesting so 93 or
is this hard to judge with this little
time there's the Seaport his see porn is
of course also dangerous and I se5 mp5
that's that's a big problem if I've know
that term kills my kills my bishop
really
taking on maybe this first check check
jam 12 seconds not good check position
is that is quite quite okay check check
check check game I need a couple of
moves to do that it's funny that I got
that I got close uh yeah I was burning
so much time when he when he finally got
this night before idea I'm not sure
really i'm not sure you know the
computer has a hair system this is the
suggestion which is quite interesting
but it's not easy for human to see ya
once you see it it's interesting that
the problem is all the ideas
something like that and now i have i
have this this possible now with with g3
is not possible because i can i can take
it it's quite quite nice so this is
another route to come to to d3 as i
wanted to wanted to to do but here i
have is having protected in the in the
game it was it was my intention to give
up the exchange maybe it's better by the
way to after 96 first take this is in
fact what the engine is suggesting with
with equal play maybe yeah there's there
should be some compensation definitely
here yeah this is I can take f31 why am
I not yeah I can take care three where
I'm not doing that yes it's pretty much
inexplicable yeah and black it's just
winning here yeah i get i get c6 bishop
deform up some of that yeah Bishop
Bishop here and stuff had said excellent
okay but I went there now we had this
this was a good move of course maybe I
should go see for him prevent his his b3
muth see for analysis again stronger but
okay I needed to be very very quick
against he for was stronger I wanted to
get the the bishop in but ok this is all
influenced by having no time on the
clock here rookie takes d2 is much
stronger yeah the problem is if we if we
consider something like that this is
just just winning for white him he has
total control now yeah it was it was
very much influenced by by the time
situation of course ok hope you liked it
thanks for watching